[Música]
qué sentido tiene que un chico no se
drogue porque no tiene donde comprar las
drogas
me parece perfecto que todos los
narcotraficantes estén encerrados en las
cárceles que es ahí donde deben estar
pero no les parece que sería mejor que
un chico no se droguen porque no elige
hacerlo
vamos a reflexionar sobre esto con un
cuento que va a expresar el espíritu de
esta propuesta
había una vez un pescador que iba
caminando junto a este río buscando un
lugar donde sentarse para ponerse a
pescar cuando de pronto ve que a lo
lejos hay a alguien en el agua que está
agitando sus brazos y gritando con todas
sus fuerzas no se trataba de un conocido
que lo saludaba sino que era una persona
que se estaba ahogando entonces nuestro
pescador suelta la caña de pescar sale
corriendo hacia una península y cuando
va pasando el ahogado lo toma de las
ropas y logra rescatarlo
pero que te digo que a los pocos
segundos miran y ahora aparecen otros
dos ahogándose y entre los dos se
disponen a rescatarlos también
pero lo curioso de esta historia
es que más tarde ahora aparecen cinco
luchando por mantenerse a flote
entretanto otros transeúntes que iban
por ahí buscando un lugar donde sentarse
para tomar unos mates y para charlar
escuchen y ven por ahí que hay como
barullo y ruido entonces dices que está
pasando se acercan y qué pasa y nosotros
y no sabemos aquí estamos rescatando
gente entonces se incorporan a este
grupo de rescate que ya estaba bastante
profesionalizado el más corpulento era
el que se metía al agua lo rescataba es
que sabía de primeros auxilios lo re
animaba los asistía pero a pesar de esta
profesionalización hubo un momento en
que no daban abasto porque curiosamente
el grupo de ahogados continuaba en
aumento luego fueron cinco más tarde
eran 10 luego 15 y después fueron 20 los
que pasaban ahogándose hubo un momento
en que no todos podían ser rescatados y
habían algunos que seguían de largo y
sabe dios qué suerte corrían
entonces dos del grupo de rescate
dijeron pero qué está pasando como puede
ser miren ustedes sigan trabajando
rescatando gente nosotros vamos a ir río
arriba a ver cuál es el problema si se
vayan vayan dicen y ellos emprenden una
caminata corren corren corren hasta que
llegan donde estaba el problema estaba
claro se trataba de un puente que estaba
defectuoso era un puente al que le
faltaban las barandas le faltaban las
maderas entonces cuando la gente iba a
cruzar se caía y empezaba todo este
periplo en el que algunos se ahogaban y
que hicieron estas personas hicieron
algo muy inteligente se pusieron a
trabajar con las personas en tierra
firme antes de que crucen el puente les
dieron recursos sobre cómo cruzar el
puente y sobre cómo nadar o cómo flotar
para que en caso de que cayesen al agua
ellos pudiesen salir por sus propios
medios
de este modo lograron disminuir el grupo
de ahogados y el equipo de rescate
empezó a dar abasto y colorín colorado
este cuento se ha terminado fíjate en
esta metáfora vemos claramente lo que
nos está pasando como sociedad
los gabinetes psicopedagógicos están
desbordados los centros de
rehabilitación por drogas no dan abasto
los hospitales las cárceles están
sobrepobladas
si pretendemos seguir rescatando
ahogados del río llegamos tarde no damos
abasto ya no quiero pensar lo que va a
ser en unos pocos años vista lo que
tenemos que hacer es ir río arriba y
trabajar con los niños antes de que
enfermen antes de que caigan al río
pero volvamos a nuestra pregunta inicial
cómo hacer para que un chico no elija
las drogas no elija la violencia no
elija la delincuencia
tiene que preferir hacer otra cosa
en el sistema educativo tradicional se
nos enseñó el mundo que existe de la
piel hacia afuera el mundo en su aspecto
matemático geográfico histórico pero
nunca se nos dio la oportunidad de
conocer el mundo que existe de la piel
hacia adentro este que somos cada uno de
nosotros nuestros sueños nuestros
objetivos nuestras emociones nuestras
habilidades
la educación emocional propone el
conocimiento de uno mismo y además
brinda un espacio para que los chicos
puedan desarrollar sus habilidades
emocionales y de esa manera poder
alcanzar sus objetivos en la vida
este tipo de educación nos va a permitir
acceder y poder conocer el propósito de
vida para que estamos aquí y poder
llevar una vida con sentido
somos libres de elegir
hay muchísimas opciones
entre las cuales están las drogas está
la violencia el consumismo el culto de
la imagen y un montón de cosas yo
propongo que además les demos la
oportunidad de conocerse a sí mismos
estoy seguro que si les damos esta
opción ellos se van a elegir a sí mismos
porque cuando uno vive en el propósito
de vida cuando uno hace lo que le
apasiona pesa mucho más que todas esas
circunstancias
la educación emocional son estrategias
muy simples es decir bajas en
complejidad con un fundamento científico
pero por sobre todo dan resultados
en una clase que estaba supervisando una
oportunidad una clase del miedo los
chicos hablaban de sus miedos entonces
estaban todos en círculo y levantaban la
mano iban hablando resulta que una chica
levantó la mano pidió la palabra y nos
contó sus miedos ella dijo yo tengo
miedo a que fulano o fulana me hagan
bullying porque me están haciendo burla
constantemente
otra chica pide la palabra levanta la
mano y dice si yo veo que a ella le
hacen burla pero yo no me animo a
intervenir por miedo a que me lo hagan a
mí también
entonces yo la miro a la docente como
preguntándole si ella estaba al tanto de
todo esto y ella me hace un gesto como
que no sabía por supuesto el bullying
prospera en un halo de hermeticidad
detectamos ese caso y empezamos a hablar
de hostigar de la seguridad personal de
cómo poner límites de la autoestima
de la empatía por sobre todo para ver
qué siente el otro es decir no esperamos
a que esa chica caiga el río se lesione
su autoestima se deprime o intente
suicidarse no lo abordamos tempranamente
en otra aula un aula virtual en una
diplomatura de educación emocional en la
que yo soy docente les explico a los
docentes que para trabajar las emociones
hay que planificar los es decir la
educación emocional hoy está
sistematizada en una serie de técnicas y
en donde si vos vas a trabajar una
emoción tenés que tomar conciencia de tu
emoción por ejemplo si vos como docente
vas a trabajar el enojo y tenés que
tomar conciencia de cómo es tu enojo que
hace es cuando te enojas qué cosas te
enojan
quizás no vayas a compartirlo con los
chicos pero tenés que saber cuál es tu
enojo a esta docente le tocó tener que
trabajar la tristeza y ella en esos días
estaba muy triste yo no recuerdo no
recuerdo porque estaba triste creo que
era porque había perdido un ser querido
resulta que es la consecuente de cuenta
a los chicos si estoy triste
y los chicos se enfatizaron y miren lo
que hicieron los chicos le pidieron
permiso al portero para que le abra el
aula más temprano y ellos se iban
turnando día a día para entrar y dejarle
mensajes en poder adores a la docente
mensajes del estilo señor te queremos
pasa a salir adelante
vos podés estamos con vos imagínense que
siente una docente cuando entra al aula
y todos los días ve que los chicos han
estado entrando más temprano para
escribir ese mensaje
este tipo de cosas genera la educación
emocional promueve el vínculo educativo
sabemos que funciona hoy lo único que
necesitamos es expandirlo llegar a todas
las escuelas por eso necesitamos una ley
de educación emocional
en primer lugar necesitamos una ley
porque necesitamos que tenga un alcance
sistémico
llegar a todas las aulas resulta que hoy
las escuelas privadas las que tienen
recursos o autonomía son las que se
capacitan en esto pero quedan al margen
de estas tecnologías aquellas escuelas
que están en zonas vulnerables o en
zonas de riesgo que son las que
eventualmente más lo necesitan no
necesitamos que sea ley para poder
llegar a todas esas aulas especialmente
a trabajar con esos chicos que lo están
necesitando
segundo necesitamos una ley de educación
emocional
porque tiene que ser una estrategia
sustentable es decir permanente de nada
sirve una estrategia o un programa de
dos años o que los talleres se den tres
veces al año no no necesitamos que sea
como matemáticas matemáticas se enseña
en todos los niveles nivel primario
secundario universitario la educación
emocional necesitamos que esté en todos
los niveles y además que sea cotidiano
de todos los días si no lo ejército
todos los días los chicos no se apropian
de este recurso
para cambiar una sociedad no hay
soluciones mágicas no por una en una
campaña del hashtag vamos a hacer un
cambio social
no hay soluciones mágicas las reales
requieren esfuerzo y por sobre todo ser
sostenidas en el tiempo
además
necesitamos que las capacitaciones
tienen tengan un fundamento científico
es decir sean capacitaciones de calidad
resulta que hay muy buena intención hay
muchísimos docentes que dicen si esto
está buenísimo fantástico y están de
acuerdo pero no todos saben cómo hacerlo
entonces necesitamos capacitarlos y
además tiene que ser capacitaciones
gratuitas el gobierno debe garantizar el
derecho a los docentes a capacitarse en
estrategias que sean acorde a las
necesidades sociales actuales
hace más de 10 años escribí el
articulado de ley con un sueño en mente
y digo esto tiene que ser ley y lo
presente en la mayoría de las provincias
de argentina lo presente en muchos
países de américa latina incluso firmé
un documental que se llamó cicatrizando
argentina en el que me subí a una moto y
recorrí de la quiaca a ushuaia dando
charlas presentando la ley de educación
emocional en todas las legislaturas de
las provincias andinas entrevistando a
docentes hoy resulta que ese sueño
empieza a hacerse realidad hoy esa ley
ya es ley en dos provincias de argentina
en corrientes y en misiones de hecho
vienen las casualidades hoy 10 de
noviembre es el día de la educación
emocional porque hace dos años atrás se
votó en el primer lugar del mundo la ley
de educación emocional en corrientes un
10 de noviembre se aprobó esta ley por
unanimidad
hoy desde el maravilloso equipo de mi
fundación tenemos hemos renovado la meta
y tenemos un sueño para los próximos 10
años
es el proyecto cicatrizando américa
latina'
en este proyecto buscamos que la
educación emocional sea realidad en
todas las escuelas de américa latina'
buscamos llegar a todos los chicos de
américa latina' para que puedan
desarrollar sus habilidades emocionales
y puedan empoderarse a partir de
encontrar un propósito de vida
quién sabe quizás se logre el objetivo
en 10 años quizás no quizás solo que de
esta charla como el testimonio de un
intento apasionado y ese es el mensaje
independientemente de los resultados es
intentarlo de corazón y que una persona
está viviendo su propósito de vida gente
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]